In a few seconds, could you explain
that to people who might go, "What the
hell do you mean conflict, confidence versus
desire to win?" It's hard to describe
in a few seconds, but I'll try
my best. So, we know that there are
a couple of factors.
There are many factors, but there's two that
we kind of choose to focus on because
they're easy to get hold of.
How confident am I in general about a
conflict? So, we'll know those people.
It's like water off a duck's back.
Yeah. I hit them with it.
I'm all right.
I can kind of tolerate that discomfort.
So, you would say you have high conflict
confidence. There are others of us who would
do almost anything to avoid even a slightly
edgy conversation. So then you would we
would say we'd have low confidence.
But it actually that's not the only story
because if you take our desire to win,
our desire to either get it right or
be right. And often we do have a
strong desire to be right because it's very
attached to our kind of sense of self.
If we have a high desire to get
it right, like solve the problem or be
right, we can often overcome a low set
of conflict confidence to go in and have
a hard conversation, but we might do it
in a way that we're overcorrecting.
So, we're kind of getting into that
inflexible space. So, we will come back
maybe
I mean it's I have to do the
online assessment because I was going wonder
what is my own default conflict style.
and you know, I was going, okay,
I can be I think back to my
upbringing, there was a little bit of
ignoring as children if there was a bit
of conflict. We got a bit of that.
And I think some I've tried to move
past that. I do in the workplace.
It never happens.
But sometimes I go, "Oh, you know what?
That person's really annoyed me now.
I'm just going to take a step back,
set a boundary,
blah blah blah." But it's not always the
right thing to do.
The other thing I loved in the book
which we touched on is this enforced harmony
within teams
and you know we see that all the
time teams like oh we've got a nice
culture
but actually
you know you kind of want some healthy
disagreement.
Is there any kind of strategies you say
that can help people
have or teams have let's call it healthy
disagreement?
I mean, I think one of the biggest
unlocks when we do the workshop with even
very senior people is making the mindset
shift between the relational conflict.
So, it's like a game of singles tennis.
Yeah. So, it's like I'm right, you're wrong,
I win, you lose, and we're scoring points
to getting into task conflict,
which is like a game of doubles tennis,
which is you and me against the problem.
And even taking that mindset of saying,
"Okay, I notice that I'm in this game
of singles tennis.
How do I get this person to join
me on the other side of the net
where we're trying to say solve the same
problem together? And in the book, there are
tons of techniques about how to do this
practically. But even we sometimes see it on
the faces of the workshop participants and
they go, I have never seen it like
that before and now I've seen it.
I can't unsee it and this is unlocking
for me how I'm going to move somebody
to the side of the net that I'm
standing on. So I think that's one of the
big things. I think one very specific and
practical thing which builds on some of the
conversation we've had is we use a phrase
in the book that has also made its
way onto a tea towel out of pure
demand. I know some of these details.
I know. I know.
I think they're actually arriving at my
house a bit of the Christmas order in
a few hours.
So, don't worry.
we'll pop your name on one.
It's get curious not furious.
And I think what's interesting about this,
which is, you know, how do you stay
in that curiosity space is that that applies
whether you're avoidant or whether you tend
to kind of go nought to 100.
Because if you're someone that goes n to
100, we're saying notice that you've got
that you're getting furious.
Just suspend judgement.
You know, if you need to, if
that means you need to walk away from
this conversation until you're in a better
place, fine, do that.
Prioritise that. Or can you just go, I've
noticed I'm getting furious to kind of start
to own the feelings and sort of get
out of that amygdala hijack in that moment
and then go, what's my prepared question
that will just at least announce that I'm
curious and get into this thing.
So, but also if we're avoidant and we're
thinking,
what will they say if I share my
true thoughts right now?
What if you were just getting curious?
Yeah, in a way, you know, so
it it's not it's get curious,
don't worry about them getting furious kind
of thing, if that makes sense, you know,
because so there's still I think I think
it's a useful phrase whichever end of the
scale you're operating on.